does anyone know the name of this man
does anyone know i'm particularly
looking at the economic students in the
room
who are the economic students there's a
few of you i know
if you're an economic student and you
don't know who this person is
um yeah that's right you're in trouble
so this individual here his name is
kenneth
hayne
you really you just just keep on digging
sorry okay
um why is this man important
well um last year he was responsible for
well actually he's a multi-year process
but
he was responsible for this document um
it's got a very long and flowery name
but you might know it as the banking
royal commission
now this kind of followed from like
global financial crisis and all this
kind of misconduct
that was sort of discovered and this is
a big deal like this was
whenever a royal commission happens it
means like something really bad happened
we've got to work out
why this took place right so like i said
there's like at least three or four
years i think
that it actually took to create things
like a thousand pages long
plus it's huge it's enormous i don't
know how many people in the world have
read the entire thing
i'm sure some people who themselves
wrote it haven't read the entire thing
but anyway
there's some really important findings
in this that are kind of going to
unleash the topic
that we're going to do for the next two
weeks until ap4s right
now who's this about right um yes it's
about
the big banks right but it's also if you
look um closely at the title it's not
just about banks
it's about um you know like brokers it's
about
all kinds of financial institutions
people who give advice all that kind of
thing
um and what did it say about them well i
said a lot of things obviously you're
not going to
unpack like a thousand pages worth of
things but i just want to point out i
think this will give you the the sense
of it right
and there are six key lessons six key
lessons
um that hane and his team sort of
they're the big summary they got quoted
a lot in the media here are the six
lessons
okay now uh principles i should say i
want you to have a look at them quickly
just just scan your eye down them this
was the report's major findings and
major kind of recommendations
to all the different financial
institutions and all that kind of thing
in response to
well i just want you to think you can
actually infer a lot about what banks
and financial institutions were doing
if this is the recommendation they were
given or recommendations right
why would you have to tell someone hey
you should really obey the law like what
does that imply about what they were
doing
they were not obeying the law um
when you tell someone hey be fair please
like that clearly
you can infer from that well their
practices were unfair i'm just have a
look at this one down the bottom when
acting for another
like when you are a financial
institution acting on the behalf of your
client right
you need to act in the best interest of
that other isn't that a terrible thing
to have to say
like hey don't be a jerk like
be be nice to people act in a way that's
that's caring to people right now
when you have a look at all these um and
all the different entities who are not
doing these things
um the big question that at least i had
in my mind when this i think was like
february last year right
is well why were they doing so much bad
stuff
like why were they taking advantage of
people and why would they you know uh
certain answers because banks right well
actually maybe that's not that bad of an
answer
because the key findings of the report
was like why were they doing all this
stuff
um entities which are the you know
financial organizations that were being
referred to here
they did these things because they could
like there was nothing stopping them and
you might think hold on a second
like surely surely there were reasons
why people would
like kind of push against this right but
and this now gets to the crux of why
this topic that we're about to introduce
is this topic right
entities set the terms which they would
deal consumers often had
little detailed knowledge or
understanding they just didn't
they didn't know like they were just
clouding all this
language and terminology and they're
like i don't know i want to borrow money
i want to
have an investment and they didn't
really understand any of the nuts and
bolts so they made very very poor
decisions and this is the way this
particular part of the report concludes
there was a marked imbalance
like this of power and knowledge
between those providing the product or
service and those
who are acquiring it and that's what
this is really
about good morning this topic
is about that imbalance and about
changing it
it's about giving you power now we've
actually been doing this all the way
through
the course maybe you want to pick up
your pen at this point right
we introduce knowledge to you and
sometimes that knowledge seems like
what is this going to have to do with
anything right for example
last year and this year we introduced
these topics right and we spent a long
time in them and they seemed quite um
they seemed quite abstract and like
what's the point of it like yeah i can
differentiate this
yeah i can integrate but what's what's
the what's the reason why i care about
this right
and we looked at that last term like
where did these two things go do you
remember the topic we did most recently
that used these two
bits of um knowledge do you remember i
think it's just like the most recent one
that we did
yeah yeah it's to do with probability
right and understanding all of this
stuff which which operates our world
right our world
functions on these principles you need
that knowledge
to have this kind of power right
now the power we've been talking about
just now and this is going to be the
substance of this topic
it's all to do with the financial world
all of these kinds of things
loans investments superannuation
all of this you like you're looking at
that if you're like me i did not do
like most of you i didn't do economics
um or commerce when i was at school so a
lot of this
i just kind of look at it's like a bit
of a black box right and honestly that's
mostly
australian it's most of world society
right
so this is power that can either be held
over you or it's power that you can
actually possess
if you have the right knowledge so i
want you to have a think for a second
right this is some of the knowledge that
we looked at over the last like 12
months and the power that we got from it
i wonder what knowledge you think that
we actually have developed over the last
year year and a half that leads to this
power
any suggestions have a think for some
past topics that might connect
to this i'll admit it's it it seems a
bit
it's going to come out of left oh wow
sarang
like getting it in one is impressive or
maybe you're like well
i've been looking at my syllabus and
these are the only things we have left
right
series and sequences we covered at the
end of last year but we did it in fairly
abstract terms
we're like oh here's a sequence of
numbers right um
it's arithmetic it's geometric whatever
and then you like find out the total or
find out this term whatever
what we're going to do now is we're
going to make it very concrete for you
we're going to look at
series and sequences in financial
situations that's actually the name of
the topic it's my
modeling financial situations
so it was a while ago we did this topic
for that reason i'd like you to make
this heading
and we're going to get our heads back
into this space